good evening everybody
welcome to the lens ik and the Santa Fe
Institute public lecture series this is
the last of this year the next one in
the series is in February for every the
12th annual Bassett the physicist who
has moved into questions of neurobiology
and I think will be a very fascinating
interesting talk she's a MacArthur
Fellow
before I introduce tonight's speaker
there's a few acknowledgments to make we
like to thank the very generous support
of the faun Berg investment management
company who have been supporting this
series for a number of years
more recently the Enterprise Holdings
foundation has been a source of our
support for these evenings and lastly of
course thanking the lens ik for
providing us with this marvelous arena
for these talks so as I say this is the
last of this year and we're delighted
and I personally am extremely delighted
to welcome our speaker tonight Michelle
Govan
she has been associated with SFI for a
number of years she was a student at MIT
and then went to graduate school at
Cornell and worked with someone some of
you may have heard of Steven Strogatz
sort of applied physicist mathematician
working on all kinds of interesting
problems and Misha and at that time
Steven was associated very much more
associated with SFI than he is now and
out of that he suggested to Michelle
that she spent some time here and she
came here in
roughly 2002 2003 and finished off her
graduate time here and during that
period she hooked up with one of our
young faculty members mark Newman
working on questions of networks and
Santa Fe Institute has been one of the
major places that has developed in
recent times the science mathematics and
ideas associated with networks of social
networks and biological networks and
Michele worked with Mark and they wrote
a couple of very influential papers some
of the most cited papers in in in the
network arena and to do really with
trying to sort out questions of
community structure and so forth related
to network structures and these have
been extraordinary influential and
Michelle after the after she'd finished
the degree stayed on as a postdoc for I
think three years with us and it
happened to coincide that period Hampton
coincide with when I was president of
the Center for Institute and we actually
worked together at that time and we were
burned I think a delightful paper
together with someone that unfortunate
is not here tonight a young student at
the time undergraduate named Chris
campus who is now on our faculty so it's
a little bit incestuous all of this but
and I got to know Michele very well both
in terms of working relationship and
just in terms of the colleague and
someone especially in those days to sit
around at the end of the day or tea
bullshitting about many different issues
and problems and so it's a wonderful to
welcome her back she moved on from the
Santa Fe Institute to take a faculty
position at the University of Maryland
has really established herself as now
one of the truly leading figures in the
whole area of network science however
that's not what she's going to talk
about tonight at least it may be she
would touch on it
she has broadened during these last
couple of years last few years and what
your what your what your here tonight is
some questions about that are gonna be
quite challenging I think for science
and society the use of artificial
intelligence machine learning and so on
in trying to understand some of the big
questions that we're facing today and as
you saw in the title harnessing the
power of chaos and predicting the
unpredictable with artificial
intelligence sort of a slightly trumpian
title predicting the unpredictable but
I'm sure we're in for a treat and very
entertaining and challenging talk but
I'm absolutely delighted to welcome her
back it's sort of you know when you see
your children grow up and start to
become successful and find a place and
they become mature people who are making
their place in society and it's really
wonderful to welcome Michele so with
that please welcome
Michele Govan Thank You Jeffrey thank
you for that great introduction I am
super excited to be here Santa Fe is my
home I mean I only lived here for maybe
five years but more than any other place
this is my home so I'm really excited to
be talking about my research with you
today so I'm gonna be talking about
predicting the unpredictable and
artificial intelligence so just a little
bit of an overview so we're thinking
about lots of different data from
different types of applications or the
main question is
how can we predict the future of some
complex time series based on past
history so we just have these data
streams and we want to predict the
future we want to make sense of them we
seen this kind of application in many
different contexts we're very familiar
with wanting to predict the weather to
predict the stock market to predict
social media behaviors and many more so
the approach that I'm going to talk to
you about today is about combining
artificial intelligence and machine
learning with mathematical modeling and
other tools to do even better than
either one of those is going to be able
to do on its own how can we combine them
in a really smart way so you heard from
Jeffrey a little bit about my career
trajectory but just to give you a sense
of my perspective on some of these
really challenging problems I want to
emphasize where I'm coming from so I was
trained as a physicist and applied
mathematician and I grew up in
northeastern Pennsylvania took physics
as a 16 year old in high school
introductory physics and I just decided
I'm gonna be a physics professor someday
so I have no idea what that was gonna be
like I only knew about you know F equals
MA that was as much physics as I knew
but it was so exciting to me that you
know you could use mathematics to solve
problems and get answers and it could
help you understand something meaningful
so that was the start for me and then I
went to MIT where I majored in math and
physics I really liked my math and
physics courses but there there was one
elective course that stood out for me
I took a course called chaos and
complexity in the Earth atmospheric and
Planetary Sciences Department and so
you'll see that that's kind of
influenced what I'm talking to you about
today so we had a few guest lectures in
that by Edward Lorenz who is known by
many as the founder of chaos theory and
so to me this was all about how you can
use math and physics and
by it - all different kinds of problems
from the weather to thinking about the
stock market to thinking about other
complex systems so when I went to
Cornell even though I was getting a PhD
in physics I was already not at all a
traditional physicist working with an
applied mathematician on these network
science problems how could we understand
the mathematics of network systems and
that's where I became involved at the
Santa Fe Institute where I had the
opportunities to collaborate with so
many different people like Jeffrey so
many like-minded people but coming to
the table with different expertise all
sort of in search of how can we find the
commonalities between these very
disparate systems what are the
universalities that link earthquakes and
stock market crashes and how can we
approach these problems with rigor so
leaving the Santa Fe Institute you know
to go on to a faculty job was a really
hard thing for me but I was happy to
find a place at the University of
Maryland in the physics department with
a big physics department there and which
means that an oddball person like me
who's not like doesn't seem like a
physicist can still fit in and the other
thing is that the University of Maryland
has an excellent group in physics and
math in chaos theory and nonlinear
dynamics so that was also a particularly
good fit at the University of Maryland
the mathematician Jim York one of our
distinguished university professors
actually coined the term chaos for use
in mathematics so that's my brief
overview and my disclaimer is that I'm
not a computer scientist actually a lot
of my most famous research is
computational right the work that
Jeffrey mentioned with Mark Newman it
was about developing an algorithm for
finding clusters and network data social
networks biological networks etc but I'm
not a computer scientist or an expert in
a lot of the areas of machine learning
but I do think that I have something
very important to bring to the table and
people from other fields you know add
SFI at other places have something to
bring to the table for these important
problems
that we're grappling with in machine
learning so this is like my formula for
me for success having this new
perspective coming as an outsider to
this field of new of machine learning
has really given me a certain kind of
advantage because I'm not bogged down in
the mindset that those in that field are
so I can think about the problem a
little bit differently but that's not to
say that you know just because you don't
know about anything about a field means
that you can make a good contribution in
that area
so it's important that you combine some
relevant expertise and this is what I
see happening at the Santa Fe Institute
over and over again you have people
coming in with a new perspective
bringing expertise that's relevant to a
certain problem but it's a little
outside of the traditional realm of that
problem so the important thing to add
there are these synergistic
collaborations so that you have people
who you collaborate with who may be more
in the core of this area that you're
trying to make applications to so that's
been my formula for my best research
successes and it's gonna be it's part of
what I'm gonna talk about with you today
and it's a little something I've seen
over and over again at the Santa Fe
Institute all right so getting back to
prediction what kinds of systems are
hard to predict well certainly the
weather and we're all kind of used to
watching these weather forecasts you'll
see these Doppler pictures of a
hurricane and you'll see forecasts of
the Hurricanes trajectory over a few
days so over the very short term the
weather forecasters know okay yeah we
know where the Hurricanes gonna be with
a fair degree of certainty in the next
12 hours in the next day there's a
little more uncertainty and you know two
or three days out we really don't know
there's this just huge area could hit
anywhere along this coast we don't know
which cities are going to be hit etc so
what is it that makes weather hard to
predict
and the answer here is sorry okay anyway
okay so what makes weather hard to
predict and the answer is chaos so what
is chaos I mean we all use the word
chaos colloquially sometimes we'll talk
about chaotic systems and systems being
hard to protect but from a mathematical
perspective when I say something's
chaotic or when other mathematicians say
this we mean something very specific
so chaos the features of tasks the most
important feature is this idea of
sensitivity to initial conditions you've
probably heard of the butterfly effect
so colloquially the butterfly effect is
the butterfly flaps its wings in let's
say South Africa then maybe that
influences a hurricane happening in the
Caribbean now when when I think about
the butterfly effect I really think
about it as the difference between two
nearby initial conditions one where the
butterfly doesn't flap his wings at that
instant in time and one where the
butterfly does laughs its wings and the
small change in initial conditions can
lead to a very different weather
trajectory down the line because weather
is a chaotic system and so here this is
an example an illustration of what we
call a chaotic billiard so we have these
two billiard balls in red and in yellow
and they're having some trajectories
starting very close by to each other but
not at the exact same point but both
under this blue star somewhere and I'm
gonna plot the trajectory of one of them
in yellow and the other in red and
I look as they bounce off this surface
the distance between the trajectories
grows in time and in fact that distance
grows exponentially so this is the
technical part that I'm going to come
back to later on so this is a technical
heart that I want you to get out of this
talk is this notion of a Liana of time
so that's the time over which this
distance between these two things that
started out really close together the
time over which that distance increases
by a factor of e Euler's number which is
2.71828 etc now in into Li up and half
times that distance increases by a
factor a squared + 3 Li up and off times
e cubed etc all right in this system
because this difference is increasing
exponentially long term prediction is
impossible you have to specify the
initial conditions precisely if you want
to predict in the long term but in the
medium term you can hope to make some
decent predictions also in the medium
term and in the long term the behavior
of these kinds of systems can appear
random in fact these even though the
system is completely deterministic the
physics is completely known we know how
it bounces off these surfaces where each
billiard is going to go but in the long
run it looks random fact chaotic systems
like this are used for random number
generation or can be used so that's one
kind of system that's hard to predict
another kind of system that's hard to
predict is one that is not deterministic
like we know all the physics and we know
if we could specify this exactly we
would know what happens next and these
other kinds of systems the systems with
randomness are ones that we call
stochastic systems and they can also be
hard to predict often having a lot of
independent actors so for example as in
the stock
market there are trends there definite
patterns in the stock market but
prediction over the medium term long
term virtually impossible other systems
where this happens you can look at the
behavior of many interacting agents have
these features of stochasticity so how
can machine learning help us predict the
unpredictable so there have been a
variety of different methods for
predicting these time series so I'm not
claiming that the group the work that
I've been doing with my collaborators is
the first in this area but I'm gonna try
to highlight what our new contributions
have been but one thing is we're trying
to use machine learning and couple it
with some other methodologies in clever
ways so here I think is a good point to
stop and talk a little bit about
terminology and vocabulary you probably
see in the popular press you might hear
about artificial intelligence
you know the artificial intelligence was
hot behind the voice recognition in your
phone or you might hear terms like
machine learning or deep learning that
has helped a machine beat a top human
player at go so artificial intelligence
is this broadest term and this field
really started at the 1950s very
ambitiously where the goal of artificial
intelligence is to have computers
demonstrate sophisticated often
human-like thinking the often human-like
part is what some people might call
general AI the big dream of AI but
there's a narrow AI which is more about
solving specific problems that are
sophisticated and hard to do and
sometimes that humans are actually bad
act that's where machine learning comes
in so machine learning is a subset of
artificial intelligence and it's all
about using computers to find patterns
and data to either classify objects
an image classification to recognize
pictures of dogs from cats from ducks or
for kids or to make predictions like
what I'm talking about today and in
these cases you don't explicitly program
the computer to do these steps you learn
you have the computer learns Baidu being
trained on a set of training data for
instance so many ways in which machine
learning is implemented is through what
we call artificial neural networks so
artificial neural networks are motivated
by the topology of your brain can we
build something that processes
information somewhat like the brain
processes information by having certain
neurons react to input having other
neurons react to that etc so that's
built on a brain like architecture
although more and more we've gotten away
from this from really mimicking the
architecture inside human brains and
that's what deep learning has done it's
taken a specific kind of artificial
neural network and develop that and it's
actually not a very brain like network
so it's a specific architecture of very
large artificial neural networks that
has driven a lot of recent success in
image classification voice recognition
and many more areas so this is a little
bit of a picture of the hierarchy so
artificial intelligence is this big
umbrella and machine learning is this
sub area really about kind of mining
data and deep learning is one way that's
been super successful almost
surprisingly successful in this over the
last several years and I'm going to talk
here today about another kind of
artificial neural network architecture
called reservoir computing that is
particularly suited for some of these
time series prediction problems and has
certain advantages over deep learning
but before I get into that I think it's
important to give you a little bit of a
sense of how deep learning works and so
this is the paradigm for deep learning
for a problem like image classification
so an image classification we take an
image and we feed it into this network
this layered network of neuron like
units so the information is processed
through successive layers and it's
primarily a feed-forward architecture so
that the information that this layer is
fed forward to the next layer fed
forward to the layer after that and so
on but these previous layers they don't
get signals that come back from the
deeper layers and the deeper layers
perform more sophisticated information
processing so in this okay so first we
have this input image broken into pixels
and this first layer of neurons has
different responses so this neuron might
fire if it indicates a pixel and a blue
pixel in one spot and other neurons fire
based on certain other properties of the
pixels and then this layer might detect
something higher order like edges it
fires if based on its inputs from the
previous layer those pixels combine to
form an edge and the next layer is
looking at combinations of edges
maybe corners and things like that the
next layer is all about feature
recognition so here it's looking at well
what's happening in the previous layer
did the previous layer detect some edge
combinations that maybe these are
actually a nose and then finally it gets
full fed into the output and you say
okay well is this a dog does it have a
nose does it have whiskers that have
other doglike features so in these kinds
of systems you know this is the basic
architecture but we have to train the
values of the weights so that for the
right input
gives us the right output so what we do
is we have a set of training data where
the images have been labeled you know by
humans maybe as these are a set of dog
images these are set of cat images and
so on for the different animals and you
feed it through and you adjust these
weights so that when you feed a dog
image through it recognizes it as a dog
and then once you've trained that system
you can feed some new images to it that
it's never seen before and hopefully it
will classify dogs as dogs one thing
that these kinds of systems do really
well is classify things they've seen a
lot of examples huh before but if
they've seen a lot of horses and they've
seen a lot of striped things but they've
never seen a zebra it won't generalize
very easily to say oh this is a striped
horse so it really needs to see a bunch
of zebras to recognize something as a
zebra in the canonical machine learning
deep learning architecture so this is
something that's great for
classification tasks but not as good at
predicting time evolution because of the
feed-forward architecture the system
doesn't have any memory so it's
responding to what it's getting at the
input at this moment but if you had
these loops inside these feedback loops
from a deeper layer to a more shallow
layer then it could have some sort of
memory and maintained response that the
neurons are still responding from some
signal it got a while back so you can
add feedback loops to the system to give
it memory which does make it better at
predicting some of these complex time
series but this makes it a lot harder to
train the weights and the reason that
happens is because the system this whole
so in the deep learning these are really
large networks of artificial neurons and
if you want to train these weights when
you have these feedback loops you can
have a pretty good weight configuration
you make a small change and suddenly
everything gets bad
so because of the complexity of the
internal dynamics it's very hard to
train the weights if you have a lot of
feedback loops so that's where this
notion of reservoir computing that I'm
going to talk to you a little bit about
today comes in this provides a simple
way to Train artificial neural networks
that have internal feedback this was
independently and introduced by Jaeger
and mass it early in the 2000s and the
main component is this very high
dimensional system that's called a
reservoir so talk a little bit more
specifically on the next slide but the
important thing about it is we want this
reservoir to give us a rich repository
of dynamics so it's capable of doing a
lot of different kinds of dynamics and
then when we add the training to it it
offers us a universal dynamical system
so that we can recreate almost any
dynamical behavior the really nice thing
about reservoir computing is it's
amenable to a lot of different simple
hardware implementations so it doesn't
have the same hardware constraints that
deep learning has so a little overview
breaking down the reservoir computing
from the input and output scale so the
reservoir is at the center of this this
is a recurrent artificial neural network
capable of rich dynamics so this simple
reservoir we think about is a network so
this is where my network science comes
into play we have this large network of
interacting units their neuron like
units and these have a lot of random
connections and there's a lot of
feedback loops which means the system
has memory it's still responding at some
time to something that happened much
earlier on and it has these internal
firing dynamics but we also need it to
process input like we want to put in
this time series right so we have input
fed into the reservoir through these
fixed random connect
so this input time Sirius is going to be
fed into this reservoir and what we want
to do is train the reservoir to predict
the next time step so we want to take
out from the reservoir the prediction
for if we input some variable at time T
we want the variable we want a
prediction for that variable at the next
time step and you can't see this but it
says delta T over there all right and so
what we do is we don't train the
internal waves that's what's really hard
to do and sometimes impossible instead
is we have this rich repository of
dynamics and we just train the output
weights so these red connections here
these are the only things we train so
you imagine you have this rich
repository of neuronal like dynamics and
you say oh well I just listened to I can
get the right answers if I just listen
to what these guys are doing a little
bit and take a little bit from over here
and add them together in this sensible
way but that simple training is very
computationally efficient and makes it
much much faster and easier to to have a
recurrent neural network so that's one
of the key advantages here and then if
we want to predict not just one time
step into the future but if we want to
predict so our normal thing as we get
the input we process it we train the
weights using our training data to
predict just one time step into the
future if I want to predict multiple
time steps we can just take the output
feed it back as input and keep running
this thing autonomously to predict
multiple time steps and in the future
but I've been telling you this all from
the point of view of the reservoir being
an artificial neural network one of the
really interesting things about this
area for us of our computing is it
doesn't have to be an artificial neural
network that's one of the simplest
implementations you know from our side
of things but
the reservoir can be a generic system
capable of rich complex dynamics has to
have a few requirements that it means
has to be an input/output system so it
has to be capable of a lot of different
dynamics depending on how you put
different inputs into it so it has to
respond to inputs and you have to have a
way of pulling out some outputs from it
and then you can later train the weights
on those outputs just like in the
artificial neural network case so one
example of this is you can use a bucket
of water as a reservoir so in this case
some researchers did this where they had
a bucket of water they had some
mechanical probes that were the inputs
sort of shaking things off at various
places in the water and then they had
cameras looking at ripple patterns on
the surface and this is an input/output
system you have these probes these input
device mechanical inputs that are
agitating the water you have outputs the
camera that's looking on the surface and
you could train this to do virtually
anything by just picking up the width of
training the weights between the input
the training just the output weights to
match whatever time series you want to
predict in those cases so this is really
promising because you don't need the
same kind of hardware you don't have to
have an artificial neural network you
can have other kinds of mechanical
devices or other kinds of devices so it
really opens up a lot of possibilities
so let me talk to you a little bit about
reservoir computing for predicting
spatio-temporal a chaotic systems so I
talked about with chaos as already
spatio-temporal chaos means that we have
a complex pattern that evolves in both
space and time and that the time of
evolution is chaotic that the nearby
initial conditions diverge from each
other so
example of this is the weather so for
the time being I want you to think of a
spatial temporal chaotic system this is
a model system that we've been working
at with as one of our test systems is a
toy system and we actually have only one
dimension of space and then we look at
time so you can think about this as
let's say looking at the weather let's
measure the pressure all around the
equator right so we only have one
dimension of space where you are around
the equator and then we're looking at
how that pressure varies both in space
on the vertical axis and in time so this
is a certain system toy system called
the Kura motor Civ ocinski system
designed to model this kind of chaotic
propagation of waves so here that okay
so you can see the features up close a
little bit it doesn't look so complex
but in fact this is if you look at
different nearby initial conditions they
diverge quite rapidly okay so how does a
system like a reservoir computer do at
predicting this kind of spatio-temporal
chaos it's sort of motivated by the
weather well here in this top panel I'm
showing you the true state so the true
state is produced by a system of chaotic
equations but the reservoir computer
does what we call knowledge free
prediction it doesn't know anything
about those equations it only is given
the simulated data from those equations
and it predicts the state so this is the
predicted state from the reservoir
computer here is the difference between
them where green is good green means the
difference is very close to zero and so
what we see here is that we obtain
high-quality predictions for about five
multiples of the lyapunov time so
remember the lis open up time is the
time over which something
but nearby distance is increased by a
factor of e so I'm five Li up and out at
time so they increased by a factor of e
to the five which is about a hundred and
fifty and so these trajectories are
really diverging for each other from
each other but we're still getting
really good predictions which is pretty
impressive but you know there are other
methods for predicting chaotic systems
so I'm not claiming that this is the
only one but it definitely has some
advantages one thing I want to point out
is if you look at these pictures
notice that the predicted States this
one looks very much like the true state
even after the predictions become
unreliable so when this isn't green
anymore the predictions are no good but
it looks kind of the same if I showed
you a bunch of these pictures you would
think oh it's in the same class if you
were doing a deep learning and an image
classification problem and here we say
that the climate is accurately captured
even after the forecast fails so in a
weather system it's still behaving with
all the physics that weather has we've
learned all that physics even if we
can't forecast for longer than these
five lay-up enough times so the
advantages that we found in this
reservoir computing approach as compared
with some very useful methods for
predicting chaos some out of the Santa
Fe Institute from the 1990s and so on is
that this method seems to capture the
climate better than other model free
methods moreover it's very simple to
implement and not prone to this some of
the spurious results that other methods
have been prone to and further scale
can't we can scale it really well to
large systems so I've just talked about
a toy model here where this is not a
system as big as predicting the weather
at every grid point across the surface
of the globe so what about predicting
really large systems so when you look at
the reservoir size that you need so the
size of the artificial neural network
that you need in order to make good
predictions as a function of the system
size that's just going to go up roughly
linearly with the system size but if we
look at the training time as a function
of the reservoir size that goes up super
linearly so if I double the number of
neurons I need I'm gonna more than
double the amount of time that goes into
training those output weights even
though this is still a much easier
training problem than the other one I
mentioned where you had to Train the
internal weights so training time as a
function of system size has this super
linear behavior so what do we do
typical spatio-temporal systems like the
weather are very large I just showed you
this toy system oh it works really nice
on this little system of equations that
produces pretty pictures how is this
useful for these big problems that you
know atmospheric scientists are
grappling with well the solution that
we've been working on is parallel
reservoir computing just like parallel
computing in general it's a kind of
extension of that so here we have many
parallel reservoirs
so each reservoir takes input from a
spatially local neighborhood so you
imagine you know we're predicting that
pressure along the equator we might have
some so the equator now is going to go
this way down this way and so this is
the input at time t1 reservoir takes in
a small spatial neighborhood and another
reservoir takes in a small spatial
neighborhood but notice that the
neighborhoods these reservoirs take in
are overlapping but they only predict us
a part of that labor hood the center of
that neighborhood but then when you put
it back in feedback and prediction mode
where you take the outputs and put them
back into the inputs then then to read
the reservoir the multiple reservoirs
talk to each other and what we found in
this kind of simple parallel
architecture
is that by testing with model systems we
have shown that this scheme is highly
effective for very large systems so now
what we've been working on is partnering
with some atmospheric scientists to use
this on real weather predicting code but
now we've gotten this goal if you let us
have as many reservoirs as we want we
can have the training time now not grow
with the system size so I talked a lot
about predicting chaotic systems and the
reservoir itself is capable of these
chaotic dynamics so you have this
complex system and you have these
different outputs that you train train
the outputs to match the dynamics that
you want but what about predicting
stochastic systems systems that have a
lot of randomness so for this I want to
talk a little bit about another very
different kind of simple test case and
that's predicting user activity on
Twitter I don't want to predict a lot of
you I'm going to ignore the tech so fear
sample data for one user on Twitter so
we have the text here of the tweets for
now we're going to ignore that for each
user we're only going to look at the
times they're the timestamps of when
they tweet and we want to do something
pretty simple here predicting by
predicting the activity of the user
based only on his or her past behavior
how much information is in that past
behavior to predict that users patterns
so what we do is divide the time into
short intervals and in this case it's
ten minute intervals so in that interval
a person either tweeted in that interval
we give them a one or not a zero and so
we want to say can we predict the user's
activity and we're making this problem
kind of hard for ourselves right our
first approach is start probably
predicting the user's activity based
only on his or her past activity and so
here this is a raster Graham this is the
user activity
over time and then for different days
running down on the vertical axis and
you know what we want to do here is
compare a few different kinds of data
driven approaches the reservoir
computing which we want to understand
well how does it work for these this
very different type of problem we can
think about this reservoir computing
approach as a top-down approach the
reservoir gives us a really complex
system and the outputs allow us to relax
from very complicated dynamics that are
contained within the reservoir until
maximum predictive capability is reached
the reservoir is like this black box
system and we can get it to match and
predict pretty well but it's kind of
hard to interpret what it's doing so we
can take instead of a top-down approach
we can take what we call a bottom-up
approach we can do something like that's
called causal state modeling similar to
hidden Markov model if that means
anything to you but if not what that is
is basically for each user we're making
a different separate model for each user
for each user we want to find the
simplest model that predicts their next
time step so first we predict their not
next time step based on just their
average behavior overall and then their
next time step based on looking just one
step in the past two steps in the past
and so on and looking at overall their
history what did they do when they had a
zero zero at the previous two time steps
the nice thing about these bottom-up
approaches is that they're easy to
interpret so in this case we build
models a computational mucosal state
model and a reservoir computer model for
each user individually we have a
training period of 45 days a test period
of four days where we see well how well
are these models performing in this test
period and then we look back for these
causal state models ten steps and
predict ahead one step for both the
reservoir computing
the top-down model and for the bottom-up
model and we compare it to a baseline
that just says well if you on average
tweeted more than half in more than half
the intervals we'll say you tweet it all
every interval if you want average
tweeted less than half the intervals we
say you never tweet it at all and you
know not surprisingly we can do better
than that baseline but actually not
always so this baseline it so the red
line is the baseline approach some
people are really hard to predict and
we're not using a lot of information to
try to predict their behavior so we've
made this a challenging problem for
ourselves so this is an improvement over
this baseline as a function of the tweet
rate for the two different approaches
the blue is this bottom-up approach and
the Green is the top-down reservoir
computing approach and both methods
showed strong improvements in prediction
for a subset of the users and but the
average improvement of the two methods
was about to say so top-down and
bottom-up work equally well but that's
not the end of the story for me what was
interesting was for some users the
top-down approach did a lot better and
for other users the bottom-up approach
did better and so we took this work in a
lot of different areas working on
prediction schemes that also into taking
account activity patterns and the users
network we can do a lot better
prediction than this just over the
baseline or just looking at the users
past history but what motivated me in
this work today was this challenge how
can we combine two pretty good
approaches that are clearly doing
different things and how much better
could we do by combining them so that's
the question sometimes we want to
combine two or more data driven
approaches like the top-down
approach or in the bottom-up approach
that I was just talking about but other
times we have knowledge of the dynamics
we know about the physics so in weather
forecasting models we know a lot about
the physics about how these weather
variables change over time and interact
with one another so can we combine a
knowledge based model that knows about
the mechanism but isn't perfect with a
knowledge free model that takes these
large quantities of data and learns
about the patterns and now in that data
so this is where we've been developing
and working on this hybrid architecture
so in the hybrid architecture we have
this input time series as before and now
the input is fed into both the
alternative models and into the
reservoir so I have this input time
series it goes into let's say that this
is our knowledge base model our model of
the physics of the weather but it's not
perfect so it goes into this the model
of the physics produces an output that
output goes is fed into the reservoir
through the input layer but it also goes
into the output layer so I'll say a
little bit about what this means
but again the output from the alternate
model is fed both into the reservoir
through the input layer and also through
the output layer and the weights in the
output layer as before we just train the
weights that come out of this how do we
weigh all the information in here and so
one simple thing you might do is you
would have your knowledge base model
your alternate model and your reservoir
and you just take their outputs and do
some kind of weighted average of them
now this is going to be so we're
motivated and doing something better
than that and that's why we feed the
output of the alternate model into the
reservoir because that allows the
reservoir to learn when that well maybe
the alternate model tends to fail if the
temperature is too high
and the reservoir can then make a
correction in that case respond to what
the state is what the prediction is of
the alternate model so that this
additional structure is important and so
let me just show you on again these toy
systems of this spatio-temporal chaos
the performance of this hybrid model in
a very simple test case ok so again what
I'm showing you is the difference
between the predicted state and the true
state but I have different ways of
predicting I have just my knowledge
based predictor and this is a low at
what I call a low error knowledge brace
predictor so this is my good model and
it predicts for a little over two li off
enough times I see this big green region
for a little over two lay up and off
times and then I take a large reservoir
so remember I'm going to I could make my
reservoir larger I usually get better
performance that's going to saturate at
some point so I can only make it so
large and still see improvements in
performance so I take a larger reservoir
a large reservoir and I also get pretty
good performance here I get predictions
for these two lis off and off times but
what was really impressive for us and
surprising was that the combination gave
us these much much longer prediction
times so the good model plus the larger
reservoir combined to give these
prediction these impressive prediction
times on the order of seven layup enough
times now so if we have two good methods
of predicting right we would expect a
hybrid method to do better than the best
one you know that's kind of the limit we
wouldn't really expect it to do the sum
of the two I mean even to think that
this would predict for Li up and off
times ahead of time that wouldn't be
very realistic for us so the way I think
about this
it's like let me use a horse-racing
metaphor so the Kentucky Derby is two
minute race all right and let's say I
had a couple of different horse-racing
analysts and they were really pretty
good that if you showed them the first
minute and 40 seconds of the Kentucky
Derby they could tell you who the top
three finishers were with with pretty
good reliability now if you said okay
well you two get together and learn what
you're doing and now maybe you can make
a combined approach you wouldn't expect
that in the combined approach suddenly
you could just show them a minute of the
video of or you know the first 40
seconds and they could very predictably
predict the winners in that kid the top
three finishers so my point here is to
say that you know sometimes we say at
the Santa Fe Institute that the whole is
greater than the sum of the parts and
that's what we're seeing here you know
seven is greater than two plus two
but we would never even expect to get to
two plus two here we wouldn't even
expect to get to four Lee up and off
times we just expect to get a little bit
better than the better one or at least
that's kind of what we were thinking so
this is one of those surprising results
and what's even more surprising is that
we can really degrade the quality of
both our palm of our model so this model
has a very short prediction time less
than one Leon out of time or we could
have a very small reservoir and you know
we might want to do that for different
you know for computational efficiency so
we might not have the computing power to
to do these bigger these larger
reservoirs so you combine those two
things together and you still get really
pretty good predictions over fairly long
intervals so that was surprising and
some of this we have explanations for
but not all of them
but I think it leads to a lot of new and
exciting open research directions so the
question here for me is can we use this
kind of hybrid scheme that that we
developed that basically lets the
machine learn how to combine the two
different prediction methods sensibly
can we use this to combine a large
number many different machine learning
approaches or different knowledge-based
models so this reminds me when I hear it
when I start thinking about this well
this reminds me of this wisdom of crowds
notion which is an active area in some
human dynamics research so this is the
notion that large groups of individuals
make high-quality collective judgments
and it was a topic of a popular book by
James Sir wiki I think this came out in
2004 and so you know one simple example
of this is let's say you're at a fair
there's a big jar of jelly beans you ask
an individual to guess the number of
jelly beans in that jar you know chances
are they're not going to be that close
and you can even ask some of the
individuals who have a pretty good
record at getting the right number in
the past so you're going to take the
best guessers from your history of
having this fair over several years and
you ask them for their guesses and you
know they're maybe a little closer than
the average person but they're still not
that good but if you instead take a big
group of people pull them take the
average of their guesses you get
something really close to the truth and
so that's this notion of the wisdom of
crowds but there's some weaknesses in
the wisdom of crowds that in many cases
having this crowd wisdom requires
individuals to reach decisions
independently so when individuals follow
one another when they see what
what others are doing and they make
their judgments on that you get less
sound judgments than if they act
independently and so this is thought to
direct to drive processes we see like
stock market bubbles and things like
that so that would be something that
presumably machines would it be
vulnerable to so that's one benefit if
we were thinking about how to combine
many machine learning approaches so how
can we think of this notion of many and
apply it on zombo's of machines where we
could think about okay well we know
about the wisdom of individual machines
how can we think about the wisdom of
artificial crowds and some of the next
steps that we can think about here are
not just artificial crowds where
everything's a machine we can combine
machines as I said before with some of
these mathematical models to give us
these important improvements but we
could also have machine human ensembles
right so a lot of times in weather
forecasting for example these machines
make predictions but at various layers
you have humans overseeing the processes
and identifying oh there's something
wrong with this forecast something has
gone off here and you need these kinds
of interventions so I can imagine you
know populations and machines and humans
and so you think okay well the machine
might not be vulnerable to these
follower type dynamics that can weaken
the wisdom of crowds but they have a lot
of other vulnerabilities one of the
largest of which is that we as humans
who are using their outputs we don't
understand how they got these good
answers it's like we see that the
machines are really good at
classification for an in deep learning
because we've learned all those weights
but even though after we go back and we
learn those weights for the different
layers if we look at those weights we
still can't interpret like why does it
sense that those weights give us a good
solution so these are a lot of different
open questions in this what about these
human machine interactions and what
about the weaknesses that machines have
we know about some of the weaknesses
that humans have so just some
conclusions here so I've talked to you
today about reservoir computing and how
it provides a promising method for
predicting complex time-series so why is
it promising because the reservoir gives
us this rich repository of complex
dynamics that we can then harness that's
the harnessing chaos part of my my title
that we have this complex system that by
just drawing from it in a sensible way
tuning these output weights we can
harness that chaos to make predictions
that to give us important insights and I
talked to you a little bit about well
how we can take this reservoir computer
scheme and do a parallelization of it
that will allow us to tackle very large
problems like not just totally models of
the weather but real models of the
weather the part that I'm most excited
about is this hybrid scheme that really
worked better than we expected and we
don't understand exactly why that's true
and so there are a lot of open questions
there so a hybrid scheme that couples
this alternate forecasting approach like
a knowledge base model with the
reservoir we see in these test cases
that offers further dramatic
improvements but the exciting part for
that to me is that the hybrid method can
offer a step towards what we call
explainable machine learning so like I
said in deep learning we train these
output weights and then the deep
learning system is a great image
classifier it's a great it's great at
voice recognition
but when we look and try to analyze this
system we don't understand why it's so
good at voice recognition to me the
hybrid scheme by combining different
types of machine learning methods
machine learning methods with
knowledge-based models it allows us a
method for hypothesis testing and
machine learning asking questions like
what what are the weaknesses of the
reservoir and how can we find that well
we can find it by coupling it with
different models so we can see that okay
well maybe when the reservoir is coupled
with a certain other kind of alternate
model that's really feeling it filling
in certain gaps and it's performed a
coupled performance is much better it
highlights a weakness in the machine
learning that we can then go on and
create better machine learning
approaches but similarly the machine
learning the reservoir can tell us about
the weaknesses in our knowledge based
model so we have a physics model of the
weather but we can look do we can look
through and do a post analysis of how
our hybrid system is performing and look
and say ok well actually our knowledge
based model is failing in these certain
areas and that's where our machine
learning reservoir scheme is having to
compensate it and it gives us a guided
way of going back and finding out what
the physics that we missed is so and
then finally you know scaling this up to
populations and crowds of machines is a
new and exciting area to think about
ensembles and layers of coupled machines
so finally I want to say that I talk to
you about a few different research
projects here and really involved a lot
of those synergistic collaborations that
I mentioned earlier a lot of very
talented graduate students mostly from
physics who have been really excited
about applying methods from physics to
machine learning I should say a lot of
this has been part
a research grant from DARPA from the
Department of Defense what they call the
physics of artificial intelligence so
they're interested in well how can we
not just have a black box of artificial
intelligence but coupl physics knowledge
knowledge based models into these
systems and also collaborations with
several faculty member both at the
University of Maryland and elsewhere
with a diversity of expertise and
mathematics computer science physics
atmospheric science and in business so
with that I'll end and thank you very
much for your time
also if anyone from upstairs wants to
ask a question we just ask that you come
downstairs to do so
okay Michelle I have one over here
how will quantum computing affect all
this and why are humans so interested in
predicting the future reasons don't you
want to know if it's gonna snow next
week okay
so how will quantum computing affect all
this that's I haven't thought a lot
about that I mean quantum computing okay
so my first answer to that is quantum
computing offers a whole other paradigm
of computing quantum computers can solve
different kinds of problems better than
classical computers but for some
problems classical computers are still
going to be very good and so it's
possible that these that what we learn
in these hybrid approaches can help us
couple quantum computers with classical
computers so that's an exciting that's
an exciting area and as far as why do we
care about prediction I mean there's
lots of reasons why I would care about
prediction but I think you know
predicting the weather is a hard problem
intellectually stimulating but also
there are a lot of people who just you
know want to predict elections want to
predict the stock market
first of all just make thanks for coming
down and that was a really great you
know presentation so you mentioned the
input layer can be kind of improved with
knowledge we have through physics models
what about the notion of for maybe
filtering for noise at the end of labor
that is an excellent question and that's
actually where I think about the
alternate model coming in so these are
alternate models yes okay so this box I
have this input data and I could feed it
through lots of different things one
thing is filters and so it turns out
that if you feed a chaotic signal plus
noise into the reservoir the reservoir
itself is a really good noise filter and
it will if you train it to just predict
the chaotic signal without the noise you
do pretty well but there are other
methods of noise filtering and that's
something that we're thinking about and
that's one of those ways where you could
use these different building blocks and
sort of test what are the weaknesses in
this black box that we don't hardly
understand a couple it with different
filters and say well we can look at
these output weights and if the outputs
weight set it might not say that well
the filtering didn't really matter I'm
just listening to what's happening in
the reservoir so we can learn about how
much the filters would help in those
cases it's a great question
what about the alternate two filters
anti filters we actually introduced
noise to move the solution space from
one area to another yes that's that's
that's a good question that's also part
of this it's not something that I've
explored a lot you know so we've done
we've used these systems on both
stochastic and deterministic processes
and I've talked about the reservoir I
didn't mention its internal dynamics but
you can you have a separate lever that
you can turn that adds noise between
these neuron like units and so the
hypothesis might be that you might need
a little bit of that noise to more
faithfully reproduce stochastic time
series as compared to deterministic ones
that's a good question about having the
noise inside as a positive thing hi
thank you for an excellent presentation
in terms of application to other systems
as a doctor I'm curious about healthcare
applications individual patients are now
complex systems in and of themselves
genomic data laboratory data radiologic
data as a doctor how do we begin to
incorporate the gamut of this and are
there applications for individual
patients so the answer to that is yes I
have one collaboration with bill Rand of
the Business School at NC State he and I
did this work together on the Twitter
data and we were looking at some
clinical time series data for patients
in shock but it's measuring different
physical clinical variables as a
function of time and looking at well are
there can these machine learning
algorithms detect these anomalies but
that that physicians wouldn't recognize
another example with this I've talked to
some collaborators about applying this
to brain dynamic
looking at seizure patterns and also
other like traumatic brain injury type
things looking at well that's sort of a
classification problem but can you see
that the dynamics and individuals with
traumatic brain injury are different how
so and so on so these things can be used
for that we haven't been doing it yet
except for the case in shock where we're
hoping to do a little bit more questions
actually one is about the reservoir and
I just thought throw out something crazy
and then secondly about the parallel
computing and the relationship between
the two and so I have some expertise in
agent-based modeling and I'm wondering
if a neural network really is the right
place to start with the reservoir and
maybe it's actually clusters of things
that have their own characteristics and
attributes and sets of interactions and
then secondly I was wondering are there
limits to the parallel computing that
the reservoirs use in other words is
there a hard limit that you're you might
butt up against these are good questions
about the inter set about the parallel
computing and some of the intersections
with agent-based modeling so the
parallel computing works really well
when on something like weather where
there are spatial neighborhoods right so
there's spatially localized regions and
we can count that you can do these we
can tile up space into these and have
these overlapping regions now if you're
trying to predict something like agents
or human interactions where the
connection patterns of what's local is
changing a lot in time you might want to
do something a little different and
actually part of our funding from DARPA
is in this direction
how do you predict agents that's not
exactly what your question was in terms
of the neural network but I'm gonna go
in a little different direction and so
you can imagine you can parallel eyes
things in that case where let's say you
want to predict the let's say Twitter
patterns of ACT Twitter activity
patterns but they're following different
people other people as a function of
time and you want to take that into
account so now instead of having these
fixed local neighborhoods you have these
time evolving now local neighborhoods
so the parallelization has to change
about which which units pass information
back and forth but we can still try to
break up that problem and make it
modular in that way and we can use some
of this like community finding cluster
detection and network stuff that I've
worked on recently so that's some of the
intersection between network science
machine learning and parallelization
that I've been thinking about
so to generalize from this it seems like
one of the things that you're you're
kind of pointing toward is that the more
types of cognition you leverage on a
problem the more likely you are to
understand it and I'm curious cuz you
know we know that the best performing
chest teams in the world are
combinations of groups of human beings
and machines and then you know the
individual human brain also has like the
left and right hemispheres work very
differently so I'm curious if you see in
forward with this like how do you
imagine this being extrapolated into a
sort of more general understanding of
knowledge and forecasting and strategies
for that there's like multiple
methodological strategies so that's a
big question and that's hard to give a
really good answer to but I could see it
being used for putting teams together
right where whether it's teams of
machines or humans or humans and
machines you realize that certain
different types of specialization are
useful for these problems and how do we
optimally combine them and you know like
in these teams for chess you just don't
get as many people together as possible
you want to do it in a smart way and you
have constraints you might only you know
be able to have so much computing time
so many humans available to you so how
can you construct those teams that give
you this excellent performance
it's a great question right here
I mean so so first of all is a great
talk second of all it sort of feels like
blasphemy as someone that works in like
chaotic time series we know that there's
fundamental bounds on predictability
governed by the reopening spectra and
for example person's identity gives
formal relations between prediction time
and you seem to be just breaking that no
no not breaking it just doing better
than all their methods are doing we're
not breaking it yes so the reason I call
it unpredictable so this is a great
question like when you think about chaos
chaos in the long term is unpredictable
and some of these prediction times are
just crazy but they're just crazy
because a lot of the methods that we're
used to
aren't quite as good and so eventually
it's going to breed breakdown I can't
predict for a hundred layoffs and
oftentimes there is this the specificity
of my initial conditions is gonna kill
me it's gonna get me some time but I do
have to say that being said it's not
breaking these boundaries but it's
getting a lot closer to them that I
expected and I'll just say this to you
as a chaos theorist the real surprising
thing is in the climate how well we can
predict the climate so we can predict
how you know so in chaos right we have
this exponential divergence so some
dimensions stretch exponentially apart
and so the positive x lio Panov
exponents are dimensions that stretch
exponentially but we also have
contracting negative exponents because
there are other dimensions that think
we're things other directions along
which things get closer together so
surprised it's not hard to predict the
positively often of exponents but we can
even predict the negative ones which is
sort of not seen in other chaos
prediction schemes and that's part of
why I say we get the climate right
that's a little technical diversion but
I thought it would be interested
whatever here hi thank you so much I'm a
complete novice with all this but is is
something like the climate really
chaotic or is it just that our
background and our knowledge base is so
limited that we don't see all of the
step step step step steps into the
future and if at that point when we are
able to measure all those tiny little
things that effect it won't be a chaotic
at all so I'll answer that as best as I
can so something like the weather really
is chaotic in the sense that in order to
that that if we don't get our initial
conditions very precise our forecasts
fall apart and the distance between our
trajectories our forecasts for close
initial conditions diverges
exponentially in time so that's our
definition of chaos right so we can do
better and better if we could define our
initial conditions more precisely but at
some level that's impossible but in
terms of the climate there are certain
features in the climate so it depends on
what you want to predict about the
weather or the climate like so hurricane
patterns are notoriously chaotic but
there are other time-series patterns
that are not so chaotic that have a lot
of regularity to them like trends in you
know the diurnal day/night variation in
temperature goes up and down in a
certain regular way so there there are
certain statistical or what we might
call coarse-grained features where there
is regularity and not chaos and it just
depends on what exactly what variables
are we trying to predict it one last
question
I was curious to what extent the neural
physiology of the brain would not be a
very good model for you in the sense
that the brain let's say in a in an
individual healthy individual put it
this way we we strive for homeostasis
and if you're predicting or climate
change or whatever
you know adverse events you are creating
it is an imbalance of the homeostasis of
nature put it this way simplistically so
how does the brain in a healthy
individual maintain homeostasis through
your filters regardless of what the
external input is that somehow the brain
manages to maintain the balance the
homeostasis can you learn more in the
let's say physics or electronic or
whatever you want to call it signals to
help you understand why some areas of
your climate hurricane explodes versus
contraction from another site so I'm not
sure if I'm in it if I have interpreted
your correction your your question
incorrectly but one point that you're
making is about the homeostasis in the
brain that you know we want to be able
to respond reliably over and over again
and is that well is is the learning that
the brain does the exact kind of
learning that we want these systems to
do and in some cases that's what deep
learning has taught us I mean when we
talked about artificial intelligence we
thought about human-like learning great
but our biggest successes in artificial
intelligence are not things that humans
can necessarily do quite as well
sometimes they think that humans can't
do very well at all in some of this
pattern recognition you know obviously
humans are good at recognizing dogs from
cats and pictures
but there are other areas and machine
learning where the machines are better
like so for instance at you know this is
a big effort in the medical field at
analyzing radiographs right and so or
other other types of bio assays
sometimes the Machine the machine
learning mechanisms do better than
humans so do we really want to mimic the
architecture of the brain and in general
we don't necessarily have to do that but
in this case there was one thing that we
did want to mimic was having these
internal loops and that loops the the
provide us the ability for the system to
have memory such that their response at
a certain time step is dependent on what
kind of input that came many time steps
before thank you very much Michelle